welcome back to 8701
so in the previous video we talked about
higher order diagrams and we looked at
how we can classify
those contributions to the total matrix
element
we didn't do any of the calculations or
we didn't calculate
the prime diagram itself
and i'm not actually planning to do this
in the lecture
what we want to do here is investigate
one of the features the very important
features of having those higher order
corrections
so if we look at this higher order
diagram here one of the specific ones
where we have a self-correction set
energy correction to the
propagator c here so you find this loop
here in the middle
and if you wear two and we have all the
tools at hand to actually do the
calculation if you're there to calculate
the amplitude
you find this term here so very good so
let's
investigate the first part is this
finite element here which we can rewrite
as q cubed
times a finite element dq times
you know all the angles which we have to
integrate around
so we find this q cubed term if you look
at
under this in this fraction here i will
find
a q squared times q square and if you go
to
just very large values of q that's the
only thing which remains
so we have an integral one over q
to the fourth power times q to the third
power
and then we have to integrate this from
zero to infinite
so if you do this you know that this
results in the logarithmic term
and if you have this evaluated at
infinite we find that it diverges so the
result of the
of the of the integral is infinity
that is a real problem now if you
calculate the scattering
um process the result is better not
infinite the cross section shouldn't be
infinite the lifetime shouldn't be
zero um so that is that is a real
problem and that actually
caused this entire theory to not really
make much progress for quite some time
because you were not actually able to
calculate anything
the solution is to introduce a cutoff
so what happens now if we don't just
don't
do the integration trend right but to
some scale
and so you introduce this additional
factor here in the
in the integral or under the under the
um
in the in the integral and you just
calculate
the the integral up to a cut off scale m
and then you have an additional term
where you have to in principle evaluate
from
m to infinite you find that that
additional element
is still infinite you can evaluate all
the other parts and it turns out if you
are smart in introducing the cutoff
you know the the theory the calculations
still remain
sensible meaning that they perform fine
under loans transformation
all the physics intuition we have is
fine
you just have the issue that still there
is a contribution to this integral which
is infinite
it turns out now by miracle that
you know you can redefine we scale
or we normalize uh the physical
objects in your calculation such that
it appears that there is a correction to
your masses or a correction to your
couplings
so what you find then is that there is a
component which is your physical value
which is a bear mass
in the bare coupling your coupling
constant
plus some correction there is still a
problem that those corrections
at infinite scale are infinite
however when we do experiments we are
performing them at a specific scale
and so this problem of you know if you
go to really
high scales things get out of hand
is actually not a real problem when you
compare the theoretical prediction
this experiment there's an interesting
feature here
when you actually look at the running or
the evolution of your
coupling which is shown here the
function of energy this shows this as a
logarithm
logarithm of the energy
you can do this for the electromagnetic
for the weak and for the strong inter
exchange and note here this is this is
the inverse of the coupling
um that they all they all run they all
are dependent
and have to be evaluated at a specific
scale
um but unfortunately that at a very high
high mass scale they don't all appear to
converge in the same spot
it is interesting to know that if i
introduce new particles along the scale
here notices
you know 10 to the 10th gev
this new particle will change the
behavior of the running of the couplings
the energy behavior of the coupling
changes if i introduce new couplings and
you can already understand this
because i would introduce new diagrams
which contribute in this way
and then those result in in a change in
the running behavior so one of the ideas
for new physics
which we might discuss in the very last
lecture of this class
is that you by introducing new particles
along the way
you are actually able to combine all of
the couplings involved here
electromagnetic weak and strong
in a specific at a specific scale and
then have a combined
unified theory describing all of the
physics
or we discuss in nuclear and particle
physics so that would be great that is
new physics and we don't know if this is
realized
however what is realized in our
calculation is that
the physical masses and couplings we
observe
there are evaluated at a specific scale
and they do run as function of the scale
as shown in this in this plot here
we will look at this very specifically
at the running of
uh you know those those three
interactions the electromagnetic the
weak and the strong
and we can also observe this when we
study the masses involved they are
have to be evaluated or are evaluated in
experiments as a specific
at a specific scale